hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the chess.com
speed chess championship uh hikaru
nakamura versus makshim
maxine vashila grav nakamura defeated
wesley so uh in the semifinals and
maxime defeated magnus carlsen and here
they are uh this is a game from the five
plus one uh
portion for those of you who don't know
the speeches championship works in a way
that they play
three mini matches the first mini match
is a series of games in five plus one
that's five minutes plus plus one second
increment then three plus one
and then in the end a bullet one plus
one so uh this is
uh i've i've waited for the five plus
one uh
section to finish and this is the nicest
game i've seen so
this is the one i decided to show you
guys and i'm probably going to show a
few more
at least one tomorrow from the other
section so let's see what happens here
nakamura with the white pieces uh opens
with e4 now sorry about that
we have c5 uh by maxine going for his
sicilian of course
uh which is what he usually does he's
the world's greatest expert on the
sicilian defense
knight to f3 and d6 and nakamura not
interested in uh
playing right into his strong hand with
an open sicilian like d4
goes for bishop to c4 and maxine
continues
knight to f6 attacks the e4 pawn uh
and here d3 defending that pawn with a6
preparing to attack the bishop with b5
and now c3 making room for the light
square bishop to escape if
b5 comes so this is exactly what maxine
plays b5 with bishop to b3
and now there are some games where
knight to b7 and bishop to b7 were
played
but here we have e6 and it's as of move
six that we have a completely new game
so let's see
how it continues knight beat d2 and this
is something very often seen in
positions like this it's actually a
position more similar you would see
against uh i mean in a rural opus than
you would in a sicilian defense
uh but you know if it works why not
bishop to b7 and here nakamura castles
we have bishop to e7
and rook to e1 developing the rook
making room for the knight
shift to f1 and then to g3 or e3
depending on what black plays
knight b to d7 and now bishop to c2
d4 is coming at some point and this
bishop will be occupying this very
strong diagonal
queen to c7 and now comes knight to f1
by hikaru and here
maxime finally castles so if you look at
the position now
uh white doesn't have much uh black uh
black uh
uh basically has more than he would have
if white played some of the main lines
uh but maxime is uh uh well he
uh he is uh much better
uh for example in these main lines than
hikaru and of course hikaru wants to
avoid this
so knight the g3 and now rook f2
e8 preparing to shift over the bishop to
f8 and the rook will be very strong uh
whoa on the e file we have h3
and now bishop to f8 as planned and here
d4 so really slow playing the position
as much as possible
uh rook 8 to c8 and now with the idea of
c captures and d4 captures and picking
up that bishop
or rather captures and captures but
white doesn't want to mess up his pawn
structure
so uh hikaru just moves the bishop so
now he will be able to recapture on d4
and here
e5 now there's a lot of pressure on d4
and he car decides to close the position
and now yeah it's a it's a better
position for white definitely
this bishop uh really locked in the dark
square bishop not doing all that much
and
black doesn't have uh uh
so many things to do but maxine finds a
very active idea
c4 he frees the c5 square for the knight
and
the bishop is under attack bishop back
to c2 and now
g6 preparing to fianchetto the dark
square bishop
as well so we have a4 uh preparing to
play captures captures and then maybe
bring the rook over to a7
in any way just opening up the a file
for the rook and now
knight to c5 as planned uh so
bishop to e3 continuing development and
now knight
f the d7 uh if the knight is captured
you could
recapture with this knight also at some
point you might be interested uh
in a move like f5 although not um not
likely uh f6 is a it would be a better
choice for black here
so knights the h2 shifting the knight
over to g4 as uh
these are some weak squares uh black has
here queen to d2
is definitely coming and then the bishop
to h6 the usual plan against duffy and
cathode
uh dark square bishop so bishop to g7
and now
queen to d2 preparing that uh bishop to
h6 maneuver
rook to f8 and now comes bishop to h6 so
uh the usual plan white would do you
trade off the dark square bishop
white has some holes here in the
position and then you push h4 h5
open up the position and attack the
black king and hopefully black's pieces
will not be able to help out
so f6 by maxine and now comes
knight to g4 uh so preparing the bishop
captures and then the queen can come to
h6 as the knight now covers that square
as well
rook to f7 and here h4 now h5 is coming
so
knight to f8 by maxine and if you look
at this position
it's uh it's a very ugly position for
black to play not a lot of
active plans you don't really have you
you have no idea where to place your
pieces
like this knight doesn't have anywhere
to go this knight can come to
fade the queen and rook not really doing
all that much of the bishop stuck
here aiming at nothing so it is a uh
maybe a very annoying position to play
but a maxim could be used to such
positions and he might be able to wiggle
out of them so knight the f8 by maxine
and now first a captures on b5 a
captures and now not going for rook to
a7 right away
first h5 this is where the action is
happening
and here he ignores it because if g5
then you allow the knights to come to f5
and it's a
it's a very ugly position for black so
instead
rook to b8 probably preparing for this
rook to a7 move and also it might be
useful later on to
play a move like b4 so h captures on g6
h captures and now finally bishop
captures on g6 and now what do you play
here
uh rook captures is an option but then
you allow knight captures an f6 with
check so uh maxine wants to avoid this
he plays king captures
and now queen to h6 with check king the
g8 and now comes queen to h4
attacking the f6 spawn and here maksim
goes back king to g7 defending the
the pawn twice and now he's hoping for a
repetition queen h6 check king jade and
queen goes back to h4
however hikaru not want to be tricked
easily
just brings another attacker into the
game rookie three
preparing to move the knight even
sacrifice it maybe bring the rook over
to the h
file checkmate the black king who knows
what can happen here
and maxime goes bishop to c8 it's a very
uh
hard position to play for black but here
uh this is a beautiful position where
white has a
very very strong idea so feel free to
pause the video and
figure out the best move for white here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting
knight to h6 as this is what nakamura
played
but there is an even greater move here
so for those of you who found
knights to f5 with check then
congratulations you are
a phenomenal player this just completely
busts open the king side
and it doesn't matter you can capture
with the pawn you can capture with the
bishop doesn't really matter
but you cannot not capture if if you
just go king to g8
knight g2 h6 is coming and that's just
game over
so here you would have to capture it
with the bishop or the pawn doesn't
really matter
because then rook to h3 this is what you
actually wanted to do just to free up
the
third rank for the rook to come to h3
and now you're threatening check you can
go
uh upwards and then queen h8 will be
checkmate
so you could try and play it out and i'm
just going to show it because it's a
beautiful line
for example knight h7 you have to give
up something to be able to escape
queen captures king of f8 now we're
going to go queen h8 capture
queen h8 check king to e7 and now rook
to h7
threatening the capture and then queen
here check picks up the queen
and there is not much you can do here if
captures captures with
czech king the eight now now comes queen
to h8 with
check king the e7 queen the g7 with
czech king has to go to d8 queen f8 uh
or uh sorry here a knight
captures an f6 would come if this is
played but if you go
uh here then just queen to f8 with check
king d7 and now knight captures and f6
is checkmate so either way so this is
what happens if you immediately go for
knight to f5 he carl played
knight to h6 instead it's uh it's uh
it's enough to win this
uh and now comes knight to h7 if you try
to move the rook for example
something like rookie seven then again
knight g to f5 is just crushing because
if after capture so rook g is coming and
you're not
escaping this knight knight has to block
queen h5 is coming and you can now try
to escape with the king
but it's uh you know it would be
pointless to even play this rook g7
queen captures on f6
king the e8 and now rook captures on g7
and it's just a terrible position let's
say bishop d7
rook g8 this is checkmate completely
crushing
so here after knight to h6 we have
knight the
uh knight to h7 and now comes knight
captures an f7 so uh maxime gives up a
bit of material to try and survive this
but now queen captures on f7 and now f4
he car
just uh uh launches the pawn forward
once the bust open the position
f5 is coming uh so bishop back to d7
and now comes f5 black doesn't really
have any active moves here if g5 just
queen h2 you're gonna
free up the h5 square for the knight
bring the rook into the game
not a lot for for black to do here so
after f5 you have rooked the
h8 now uh trying to use the h file for
black's rook but now
f captures on g6 uh and again not
not a lot to do here uh queen captures
and g6 displayed you could also try
knights to f8 to open up an attack
towards white's queen but then you first
capture the rook with
check king captures and now you grab
this you wrap a whole rook and also up
the exchange
uh completely winning for for hikaru so
after f captures we have queen captures
on g6 and now
finally knight to f5 with check uh here
maxine played bishop captures and the e
captures on f5
and it was in this position animal 38
that maxim barcelo grab resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
uh they had a lot of time on the clock
they had like two and a half minutes
each uh so
uh time wasn't an issue here black is
completely busted uh so here
you resign because if you try to go this
way then just rook g3 let's say wins the
queen and if you try something else
let's say you bring the queen over to f7
then you can pretty much play anything
rook g3 check king f8 queen to h6 check
king to e8 now comes rook to a8 check
let's not forget
about our good friend the other rook uh
rook a8 to check
king is seven and now rook a7 check uh
there's nothing for
for black to look for here rook the g7
is coming it's completely crushing this
is a
this is a disgusting position even to
look at i'm just
might i just might use it for a
thumbnail even
uh but yeah that's uh that's the game i
do hope you guys enjoyed it so like i
said it's from the five plus one uh
minutes section
uh we're going to show some other games
as well hikaru is leading by a one point
margin after the five plus one section
uh we'll see what happens in the three
plus one section and then of course in
the one plus one bullet section
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game i do
hope you guys enjoyed it and that you're
enjoying uh the the speed
the chess.com speed chess championship
uh i would like to thank
elena barrera uh sean sean granger uh
robert fisher vladimir gonzalez and uh
emery we are for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh robert fisher said that uh if i ever
want to play him i can and then i can
say i defeated robert fisher it might
not be a bad idea to use it like
like as a clickbait uh matter faces
robert fisher
uh we'll see if we can make it happen uh
that's it for this video thank you all
for watching and
i will see you soon